out of any
easter egg you have ever pointed out
that is gonna make the top ten that will
forever stay in my memory right there
how's it going reject nation i am so
excited to watch this today new rock
stars episode 8 of what if what if
ultron won you know it's gonna be a good
one after that amazing episode i want to
thank everyone who uh commented
repetitively in regards to our initial
response to when ultron killed thanos i
appreciate that especially after we uh
pretty much addressed all those exact
points towards the end of the review but
i know most you guys don't make it that
far
so you know maybe next time i don't know
stick around yeah we might bring up the
counter argument already it's just not
the time to unpack it when the show is
moving
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
what if episode 8 what if ultron won a
truly terrifying age of ultron that even
the watcher and his fighting pjs can't
stop this episode was filled with
interesting easter eggs and mcu
implications so i'm gonna break it down
frame by frame for everything you might
have missed we open on the watcher his
outline framed in the snow of
post-apocalyptic moscow unlike past
appearances his silhouette has retreated
behind the elements of our atmosphere
reflecting how powerless he now seems
this episode with the we're scared of
russia pieces of himself as he risks
dematerializing into obsolescence he
laments we've seen this before a
universe in the final days of
destruction
but this
particular story
this
this one breaks my heart i'm curious
about the exact timing of the watcher's
narration by we've seen this before he
seems to be referring to past
apocalyptic episodes he's shown us like
the doctor strange and the zombies
episodes but it's not clear if this
watcher was the one who reacted to
ultron's arrival to party thor in
episode vii so is the story that breaks
his heart the story of ultron's
destruction of earth that we're about to
see and he's now speaking to us right
before the moment ultron sensed him or
are we seeing a truly defeated watcher
speaking to us as a ghost beyond his
cosmic grave and his heartbreak is
really coming from the story of what
ultron is about to do to the multiverse
in the second half of this two-part
finale event that's actually a really
great question because he does show up
at the end ultron shows up at the end of
the party thor episode and he's like
what and then it starts off this one and
he's just like i'm telling another story
yeah and i'm surprised again when ultron
senses me yeah because i think the
initial assumption is that this episode
is set before the events of party thor
which would explain how ultron got over
there but then that doesn't line up with
the watchers narration at the end of
party thor and how this ultimately
progresses and where it lands by the end
of it and i didn't think about the
possibility of like multiple like the
two different watchers i thought it'd be
the same is there a multiverse of the
veil between
that's not what the rules established at
least no i don't know let's let's hear
some more i have some thoughts on this
later but here natasha romanov roars
passed on a motorcycle her taillight
bleeding a streak of red like blood in
the water luring some predators in this
case ultron sentries meanwhile clint
barton's arm was replaced with one from
an ultron sentry showing how in this
machine-dominated post-apocalyptic world
he must supplant his flesh with pieces
of that which he hates but it's worth
noting that this is now the arm involved
so he does benefit from the
technological precision of those robotic
motor functions clint's close is made
from the same mesh fabric that natasha
and melina and sharon carter have used
for cloaking purposes
does rely mostly on his century arm to
do the heavy lifting but as he fires a
hole through one of their heads notice
how the camera frames his human hand
through the kill hole a way of showing
triumph of man over machine and attack
yeah that's a beautiful detail he'd need
a hand claiming puns aren't her style
yet notice the next line puns aren't
really my style
we're getting rusty
getting ready
get right in rust yeah she loves puns
then
i love she loves posing i see a suit of
armor around the world a direct quote
from age of ultron i see a suit of armor
around the world back then tony designed
ultron to operate his iron legion an
idea he pitched to bruce banner and i
love how in that conversation it
inspired this what if hypothetical given
the little exchange between them in that
moment that's a mad sized if
our job is if ultron goes online hey
in his later form not the disembodied ai
he was born as in the film and then
shortly after the broken iron legion
drone actually that was the same one
that the scovian protester defaced in
the opening scene of the movie but then
this ultron cross dissolves into the
body that would later become vision
resting in the cradle in helen show
south korean facility this transition
neatly shows how ultron successfully
merges with the vision body this time
instead of helen cho pausing the upload
at 42 in the film and notice how when he
opens his eyes they glow ultron red the
color that shows his consciousness in
any given century drone contrasting
vision's blue eyes but remember helen
show is only able to stop that upload
when wanda max moff dispelled her from
the mind stones mind control it's just
worth noting how many of these nexus
moments really come down to the
decisions of wanda maximoff or steven
strange who will be the pivotal
characters and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness i'm surprised we
haven't got any what if episodes would
like wanda yet i know except for the
zombies one pretty much right we've
gotten so much like vision and then
we've got it even a doctor strange and
yeah we're dealing with multiverse
events i feel like we would have got at
least like one wanda by this point maybe
they just want to make us miss her for a
little while until dr strange too comes
out and speaking of nexus the avengers
defeat by ultron goes down in the nexus
internet hub in oslo norway seen briefly
in age of ultron when tony stark tried
to track ultron's movement through the
internet and is this just the center of
everything i'm just a guy looking for a
needle in the world's biggest haystack
oh
i'm decrypting nuclear codes and you
don't want me to
aha so ultron ascends on its path toward
becoming a nexus being at the nexus
internet hub now theoretically ultron's
assimilation d occurred right as tony
made that crack about the nuclear codes
which could have actually led ultron to
this place to initiate global nuclear
annihilation which is way more fun to
wipe out the human race than throwing a
chunk of a city back at the surface you
don't have to do this i made you for
peace it's evolution only a primitive
mind would fail to see the distinction
which is why you have to die now
replacing james spader as ultron this
episode is ross marquand the voice of
red skull yeah i've heard some people
say that ross marquan wasn't even going
for a james spader that he was doing his
own voice i feel like he was going over
a dave spader at least somewhat of a
james spader because he's got his james
spader drawl yeah that's what i mean
completely disagree with people who have
that assessment i feel like it's very
intentional the voice he did was
supposed to make you think is that james
spader
now notice the visual of cap's shield
broken in half and his body strewn
alongside those of thor and hulk as
stark is just left to watch it all this
is exactly tony's nightmare yes
yes
and this episode makes it the fourth one
to kill off tony stark really the only
avenger to die on screen in every repeat
appearance on the series it's almost as
if this guy needs to die for the
multiverse to move forward i actually
have a video coming out in a few days
exploring how stark's death may actually
be an absolute point i think it
absolutely is especially with the way
how it's affected the whole of the mcu
and and where we're at now definitely
seems like an absolute point he does die
in all the what-if episodes and i do
wish because that point that he just
brought up about how this is the
fulfillment of the nightmare that he has
at the beginning of age of ultron that
he doesn't really bring back until later
on in the mcu franchise i think that
would have just made this episode hit
that much harder and especially that
moment too if we didn't just kind of
brush past it really quick it would have
made it hit that much harder if these
episodes were just like a few minutes
longer we could have really seen this is
the fear of the debate that uh bruce
banner and iron man had with each other
over creating this and of course it
would have made that nightmare feel much
more complementary and complete to this
whole what if scenario would have been
such a striking moment if they had
really taken advantage of it now during
the sequence the watcher's hand swipes
over the frame transitioning it with
this kaleidoscopy texture from the main
mcu reality to this alternate one these
what did happen slides have always had a
storybook aesthetic in past episodes and
now we see why because to the watcher he
is flipping through the pages of what's
essentially a comic book that he's
already read and in his case appearing
from one crystalline comics collection
thaddeus ross watches in horror as icbms
strike all over the world notice that
one icbm from the texas region if you
follow it's trajectory it's headed right
for wakanda which ultron must be
recognized as a global superpower
alongside the us and russia and china
thanos portal
now he already possesses the power space
reality soul and time stones meaning he
must have begun his stone quest earlier
in this universe perhaps ultron killing
the ancient one in stone
nuclear blasts could have cleared a path
for thanos to go to zandar for the power
stone to asgard for the space stone and
so on however gamora is still alive on
the sovereign so he could not have
sacrificed her on vermeer to get the
soul stone now gamora could have
sacrificed nebula to get the soul stone
but would she have parted ways with it
without giving it
see folks when it comes to the infinity
stones this show doesn't really consider
their exact continuity that big a
priority it turns out so we are best
talking about things possible other
universes the stones are wherever they
need to be for the story
that's a hundred percent sure i i've
seen so many debates and i'm wondering
if boss is really going to go into it
here but like i thought they couldn't
work if they were not in their own
universe of origin yeah which i'm sure
he'll go into uh after ultron takes the
stones what i thought that this show
might attempt to do with this specific
storyline was address thanos watching
over ultron because they have that post
credit scene where he grabs the glove
and go with a vine i'll do it he'll do
it himself and so that's an indicator
that he was hoping
at least the way he would play a part in
this whole thing
and grabbing the infinity stones or if
there was actually some post credit
scene they threw into the mcu i thought
they might do something there once i saw
where this episode was going but
apparently not yeah no and i mean that's
been another theme is like as much as
we've seen tony die i feel like we've
also seen thanos show up and just you
know be a joke ultron uses the mind
stone to slice thanos in half on
avengers tower what the hell well i
supposedly consider that thanos could
have been clouded by his malthusian
ambitions and by comparison ultron as a
super efficient robot brain could have
quickly mastered his stone's fullest
potential to get the draw on this
eco-terrorist who's still figuring out
how his toys work exactly but uh yeah it
is nuts to see ultron wield the mine
stone so perfectly to fillet thanos and
melt a nidaleer gauntlet at least we
know how uh voss feels about it yeah
thoroughly on team it's hilarious to
watch thanos go out like a punk
that's gotta be like the most hotly
debated aspect of that comment section
yeah i mean i i also don't agree with
that assessment too people were like
vision treasures life he values life
that's why i want to kill thanos so i'm
like but in an exact movie you're saying
that all right so i could get on board
when maybe he couldn't use the mind
stone because it was loose after shuri
was doing work on trying to remove it
and i could even get on board with uh he
was weak so maybe he couldn't use it
fine but you can't say he wouldn't kill
because he kills someone like minutes
before
he dies in infinity war and this is like
that ultimate moment of like well given
the extremity of what this person's
about to do thor's gonna try it i might
as well give every weapon i have a
chance or i mean if he had that ability
he could have even sawed off his arm i
also don't agree with the point of
people like he doesn't just mercilessly
kill okay yeah if dados just showed up
he wouldn't just kill him but after the
invasion of wakanda being forewarned
about thanos having the black order
attack there's enough precedent set in
place where vision could kill him on
site if he had the capability to use the
laser all right and so ultron plugs in
the five remaining stones into his new
armor wow
there are worlds that needs
me
yeah notice how the stones emit that
heavy
tone the same sound that we heard
thanos's gauntlet would make an infinity
emitting stone energy
ultron materializes an army of sentries
using the reality stone but also they
come together in this black ink dot
effect now in comics this is known as
the kirby crackle or the kirby dots
created by artist jack kirby who would
use similar dots to convey cosmic
negative space around energy these kirby
dots return most of ultron in the
watchers attacks later in this episode
and it elevates ultron to a jack kirby
cosmic level character like galactus and
i love when the show uses ink in this
way like how they should dr strange's
universe melt back into comic book style
inc the base elements that form all of
these characters ultron destroys
it i think the image
like when those alien battleships strike
skyscrapers and independence day
yeah that's a good call
but if you go through frame bright frame
as asgard explodes
pouring down from the edges of the disc
vaporize before the whole plane
obliterates just like it did when surtur
destroyed it and thor ragnarok then on
to the sovereign which you remember from
guardians vol 2 and we see peter quill
and gamora and drax fighting on that
same platform that they fought the
obelisk and since this is in 2015 this
is a place they already would have been
to because guardians volume 2 takes
place a month after guardians vol 1.
then we go on to sakar where centuries
pour into the grand masters arena you
can see korg fighting alongside that
strainer-headed gladiator from thor
ragnarok who also cameoed in last week's
party thor episode grand master dies in
the blast as well and then ego gets hit
looking just as he did in guardians vol
2 the craters on the surface make his
face in a shocked expression
the other half of the universe yet and
then on to xandar which of course you
saw in the first guardians during the
century attack the nova corps tower does
appear to be under reconstruction not
just wreckage that ultron has just
caused but apparently some attempts to
rebuild from some past conflict i
thought it was just from ronin's assault
in the first guardians film but at the
end of that movie it was not this much
under repair so we might be looking at
the aftermath of thanos's recent attack
to steal the power stone it would
justify how he got that stone at least
captain marvel
i've seen the killer robot movie and i
gotta say i really don't think it needs
a sequel determination skynet referring
to the robotic ai computer network that
nukes the planet in the terminator
franchise but this line about the sequel
well we know carol got addicted in 1989
and returned to earth
with the scrolls she did land in a
blockbuster but i don't think she had
enough time to know that a sequel to the
1984 terminator the amazing t2 judgement
day of 1991 was a way better film so
this killer robot movie that she was
referring to totally needed its sequel
and her wrongness on this point in my
opinion makes her deserve to lose to
ultron
yes that's probably out of any
easter egg you have ever pointed out
that is gonna make the top ten that will
forever stay in my memory right there oh
god that was so brilliant
what's he said 89 it was like oh she
never saw it next she's gonna say alien
didn't need aliens oh so good so good
matrix and t2 are pretty much done it's
my favorite movies of all time i
especially appreciate that ultron was
just about to call it quits it's done
at last
the realization nearly broke the machine
should have kept your mouth shut
the watcher monologue in here did amount
to intervention because had he said
nothing ultron may have self-destructed
or retired and never thought to move on
to the other universes so the watcher
has already kind of intervened he's
gonna have to intervene to undo his
intervention even after ultron senses
him behind his back the way dr strange
did in episode four the watcher
continues who said that basking in the
boundless silence of his universe ultron
ascended to a previously unattainable
level of consciousness he became aware
of another he became aware
of the
i see you that
i hope i hope this is addressed the next
what-if episode yes
like it's my fault i i couldn't help
monologue i get really into the stories
i'm sorry i didn't realize that it was
echoing my exact experience in the
moment it's almost equivalent to that
sitcom joke of when people are in a
court case and the person typing is
typing every single little tiny word
character gets really annoying doing
that yeah
this moment of realization is odd
because yeah again we saw a separate
moment of the watcher first scene ultron
infinity at the end of the party thor
episode so when did the watcher first
recognize ultron as a multiversal threat
then or now well the watcher does say
here i have seen everything that has
ever happened ever will happen ever
could happen and yet what the hell is
this now yes there are multiple watchers
in existence but i think this one voiced
by jeffrey wright is just the same
watcher that we saw at the end of
episode seven and i think this is his
way of describing how he is just a
multiversal being with his perception
divided across an array of moments in
history kind of like he who remains he's
able to see the past present and future
all at once and we have one set of his
eyes reacting to ultron crashing party
thor and another set of his eyes
reacting to ultron here and that only
when ultron responds to him behind that
prison wall despite him trying to wipe
the blind's clothes does he finally see
him as an existential threat to his
script hmm
actually is a pretty solid point but let
me add on maybe he's just quentin
tarantino in it that's right
somebody
the multiverse is playing out all at the
same time everything that could happen
but hey man these are the specific words
i chose to tell the audience what's my
good fellas opening now how did we get
here this is my 100 million ninth draft
of these stories and i think they're
pretty good we need an opening sting and
the heartbreaking aspect of the story
that the watch at the beginning of the
episode is talking about is literally
ultron breaking the heart of his prism
multiverse that's why this story breaks
his heart more than the others also
notice how much the water there's some
links here that was a little detail i
pointed out last week is just a bit of
evidence of uwatu's human-like all
ability and now he blinks like crazy as
if trying to wake up from a dream so
much blinking like that were to be
unleashed upon the multiverse even i
cannot imagine the horrors that might
follow yeah the hunger is also the name
given to the zombie virus in the marvel
zombies comics a virus that spreads
across universes in the pages of the
comics unlike in the show so i'm
wondering if this show could actually
follow through on what the virus is in
the comics and that the watcher could
try to use that multiversal hunger to
neutralize this multiversal hunger
interesting that's a good idea but if
that happens then that zombie thanos can
get his revenge that's right he can he
can laser ultron infinity in it he's got
all the stones too but my question about
that would be what are they going to eat
because he's a robot and his robots are
also robots they're just metal i don't
think it's going to come back
maybe probably
i mean there's got to be at least
another zombie somewhere clint and
natasha seek a zolophile in a kgb
archives warehouse that clint compares
to the final shot of raiders the lost
ark and the camera tilts up in both
versions of the shot he also later
references star wars the death star
plans are not in the main computer and
natasha says hard copies are harder to
steal easier to destroy but code
code is slippery and it never dies the
lesson they learn from ultron of course
but also one that they will apply to
zola perhaps foretelling how they might
not be able to kill ultron permanently
but rather they have to find a way to
contain him natasha finds the shield of
the red guardian alexey shostakov from
black widow he did not have that shield
in the black widow film but his action
figure did in arnhem zola's file box
there are some other names in cyrillic
letters i didn't take the time to
translate these oh wait of course i did
they seem to be the names of a bunch of
artists who worked on the what if series
there's paula sane he's the what-if
production designer then molly sotak and
fran portillo they're design
coordinators from marvel studios then
cynthia halley and peter bertucci those
are marvel studios artists and then in
the later shot as natasha thumbs through
these you can see joshua bramley he's
the what-if asset supervisor and then
sean something and then el grasso and
then zachary split up into two words and
then may fam maybe my family i'm just
assuming all these are crew or friends
and family these are just the ones that
i spotted how dare you become lazy and
not figure out exactly what every one of
them does and also provide us with
pictures of that you should be making
calls to their families getting details
on their upbringing laziness dude at
maximum level there eric vos i was gonna
remember this for that thing about
terminator but now i'm gonna remember it
for your utter lazy shortcomings
no i appreciate that
i didn't actually mean it please five
sorry joke is that very much did way
more work than everyone else the watcher
begs using the same exact words that
tony stark did begging for his life you
don't have to do this which probably
gives ultron even more resolve to bring
peace to all of existence by silencing
it i have a question if the infinity
stones essentially become rendered
obsolete if you throw them into the tva
couldn't the watcher because i get where
people were getting at with that point
but could the watcher somehow guide him
to just sort of be in like the tva
sphere obviously he dominates off of
more than just the infinity stones
what's really aiding him now in his
quest is the infinity stones yeah and i
mean i already thought they were only
supposed to work really well in their
own universe of origin so i'm like how's
he gonna do this when every single other
universe i mean he does get the drop on
the watcher so i could see how it's like
well he doesn't have time to like get
him over and maneuver him over there but
yeah you'd think that he could just kind
of find a doorway there and you know
neutralize the entire situation if he's
going out there and breaking the fourth
wall and and destroying like these
timelines and multiverses wouldn't the
tva have cause to intervene maybe go
back and prevent some of this
i think that like age of ultron would be
always wiped from the timeline forever
just for the potentiality of this
outcome i don't know what do we know you
guys tell us tell us why we're wrong
natasha and clint find the same siberian
hydra base from captain america's civil
war but here the tanks that contain the
other winter soldier assassins are now
all empty hydra might have deployed them
to try to stop ultron and obviously bail
the arnhem zola algorithm comes back on
this computer terminal
of course similar to how he greeted
steve natasha camp lehigh and captain
america winter soldier except now he
calls them agents of shield r.i.p so in
addition to zola's a.i presence living
on in camp lehigh secretly corrupting
shield as hydra zola was also present as
a backup in the same place that tony
stark realized bucky killed his parents
and cap knew about it leading to their
fight makes me wonder how maybe in the
main mcu zola could have been a silent
partner to zemo and help supply him that
footage as a way to haunt the avengers
from the grave of hydra and giving one
last fu to captain rogers that's
president rogers to you i think uh all
that happened was they added it into the
what if show and at the time the most
the writers of civil war did not
know about zola being in the base but
now it's gonna look like it was the plan
all along that's that's what this show
is the best for marvel tv look each
other like can we say
does it does it negated it no
it was a plan all along a little boy in
iron man 2 was definitely spying
parker 100 either way folks zola lives
now they tried to use zola to infiltrate
ultron's code via his sentry hive mind
the same way that he infiltrated shield
and clint does this by downloading him
in one of his arrows using that same
awesome usb drive arrow that clint used
in the first avengers film and he plugs
it into an ultron sentry with some cool
color coding here zola's ai green
replacing the ultron red go light and
stoplight they climb the same silo that
stark chase cap and bucky up in civil
war we see various alternate functions
of clint's arrows like laser netting a
force field barrier and one that just
has a powerful boom boom which might be
what clint is referring to with kate
bishop in the upcoming i love the way
they animate the explosions
mostly hawkeye versus predator
yeah
oh
give us that one
natasha's death an end game clint forces
her to let him go actually in the first
avengers film clint dobin turned back
upwards midair to fire arrows up but
here he turns mid-air downward to face
certain death i love this shot attempt
at the swarm of centuries beautiful
composition notice how they tilt the
whole silo at an angle to make clint's
drop look like a deliberate strike and
then they widen out the silo way larger
than it actually is in order to heighten
the contrast of the one versus the many
to give it all a more epic scale natasha
the pose that elena made fun of her for
and black widow meanwhile the watcher
and ultron duel and it rules we want to
withstand a double blast of the reality
stone and the time stone though note
that in this domain which might be
uwatu's version of the mirror dimension
based on how it looks ultron doesn't use
the practical functions of the time
stone of the reality stone like
rewinding the flow of time or like
turning uwate's robes into beetles
they're simply just big energy blasts
and that might be a limitation of the
stones outside of any one reality like
you still remain an all-powerful mix of
god but these specific unique functions
of the stones themselves might not be
exactly usable here now the watcher
defends himself
i cannot exert my will on the natural
order of things i cannot intervene to
whom did the watchers swear this oath in
the comics
the one assigned to our universe and we
know others existed in the mcu from the
guardians volume 2 scene but we may have
to see who want to answer to his fellow
watchers for his interference uwa 2
blocks
the watchers and the celestials have an
antagonistic relationship in the comics
over whether or not to interfere
watchers swear not to celestials can't
help monkeying with the monkeys but
notice how huawei suits up in this
combat armor kind of like the watcher
aeron the renegade from the comics but
the fact that roberts have armored forms
just like the celestials have these
armored forms might be a clue that these
two entities might have been at war with
each other in eon's past i think there's
a really great boring ass star wars
episode one political prequel movie to
make i want it
i don't want it watchers just them in
one room talk in a debate debating about
whether or not to interfere and then by
the time they make a decision it's much
too late yeah
i just want to see them debating while
the audience is itching to can you just
cut to what they're talking about
already please
12 angry celestials ultron tackles the
watcher through these different worlds
we see this pyramid planet then an ice
planet then this interesting molten lava
planet actually looks a lot like
mustafar from star wars there is a
castle in the background that looks like
vader's fortress and come on
and then another ice planet and then
this rock planet with floating columns
that a gargantuan ultron bites down on
lumen even larger than the whole galaxy
clearly a nod to galactus devourer of
worlds an entity that we have been
pining to see in the mcu i think it's
the show's way of striking fear in awe
of ultron infinity as a galacticized
threat but even the last doesn't consume
celestial bodies out of spite like this
he's driven by a custodial drive to
murray condo the universe of dying
dysfunctional planets then the watcher
crashes into times square with onlookers
including that pineapple shirt guy from
vegas yeah episode 7.
olympia the musical as we saw in times
square in episode 3 but nothing yet
about roger's the musical because i
guess here steve rogers is taking the
president to become the u.s president
something that does happen in the
ultimates comics but perhaps in this
universe steve rogers only ran to
prevent candidate loki from becoming
president that's not how that loki got
pruned to the boy ultron's punch turns
time square into wakanda and then to a
medieval castle and then to the skrull
society this could be their throne world
of tarnac's four and then ending on
another frozen planet bringing uwatu
full circle with the snowy beginnings
this episode notice how as ultron tries
to crack the watcher's head like an egg
steam sizzles off of it in the cold air
and this is also the way captain marvel
tried to implode ultron's head on zandar
just showing how with every fight ultron
is learning a new way to kill someone i
just gotta say doesn't watch you like an
adorable like this is so good this is a
baby head giant baby head
on a regular buff guy body
it's so adorable i just want to cuddle
him so the baptist seems so cute but the
watcher is able to break free and
retreats to his purple sphere where back
in episode 4 the watcher left strange
supreme this time the framing is
reversed from their first encounter
uwatu now looks over his shoulder to see
strange creeping up behind him
she's still part of him but of course uh
come here because strange is the one
other nexus level being he might know of
who might be able to help him fight
ultron are you ready to break your oath
yeah interesting to hear strange talk
this way as a doctor bound by his own
hippocratic oath to do no harm but that
doesn't apply to robots i bet the
watcher changes his tune i see now
i need your help
[Music]
and the shape has changed yeah notice
how the music shifts here from a
dramatic orchestral swell and choir
shrieks to a simple acoustic guitar
melody over the credits it was the music
of dr strange trying to work past his
absolute point episode 4 and now
reflecting this new cooperation between
the two i think we can expect their
solution to be one part using zola's
algorithm to de-link ultron from his
hide mind one part using the hunger
virus and another infinity stone armed
threat and ultimately since ultron
remains a slippery code impossible to
eradicate fully
trapping him the way strange supreme was
trapped perhaps by breaking the
multiverse in such a way to leave it
impossible to navigate maybe what that
opening imagery of every episode showing
spiraling broken shards has been
foretelling us this whole time and of
course i think this series is going to
set up the mcu with a broken chaotic
multiverse ahead of titles like
spider-man no way home and doctor
strange and multiverse madness
checking out our merch options
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thanks for watching bye
thank you
[Music]
thank you guys so much for being here
you rock stars you wrestle you're the
best you are the best you are
thebomba.com
yay voss you are the ultimate boss
man that was awesome that was that was
that was beautiful
epic terminator 2
carol danvers i blame brie larson just
because she improved that line yeah
she's like hey i know i'm not doing the
voice let me throw a line away
let me pitch you something guys
i'm in the room thanks for being here
see you guys soon